we haven't shown in 21
that that their company phones the
telephones are kalenna it was a group of
concept that we did so we could because
pretty much we have not seen hope st.
much except for Spanish so this was a
chance to see what I'll do with the name
I should you must hermana
this is all hallmark
so we're going to test for temporal -
curacy we're gonna send you out for
about 10 minutes and pull you back in a
few seconds I hope it works
laughs you're out there
come on tell me can I just do this by
myself
you never trust me you'll always think
I'm the messed things up
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie this is gonna
be my breakdown of the new deleted scene
of world breaker Hulk completely
freaking out destroying iron man's lab
and there was also a deleted scene of a
Hulk versus Thanos rematch fight that
they revealed recently - so we'll break
it all down we're doing the giveaway for
the Disney Plus streaming service all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best Hulk
Marvel phase 4 theory on the video I'll
start with the world breaker Hulk stuff
then I'll talk about the Thanos vs Hulk
rematch fight then I'll talk about
what's going on with Hulk during Marvel
phase 4 because he is coming back for
the Marvel phase 4 stuff so the scene
actually picks up an Iron Man's new
Armory inside the now-former Avengers
Base in upstate New York
after avengers endgame it's just a hole
in the ground maybe they put a park
there or something like that but the
idea is is they're going to have to
build a new Avengers base somewhere else
when we get to Avengers 5 but that
movies not gonna come out for a long
time the reason why they're saying
they're releasing this scene now why
they didn't release it earlier is
because it was a special panel at d23
where the visual effects artists that
work on all the Avengers movies did
their own special panel talking about
all the cool stuff that they did that
did not wind up in the final cut of the
movie and as you would expect the visual
effects artists are the ones that come
up with the best craziest stuff that
never winds up making it into the movies
even better there was another scene that
they showed off with ant-man in Giant
Man form doing a fastball special or
triple fastball special because he was
getting ready to throw hulk wolverine
colossus style but just to give you a
sense of the scale Holt was also holding
spider-man getting ready to throw him as
well
triple fastball special that would have
been the most badass thing ever to see
during avengers endgame even the writers
during Comic Con did their own special
panel just about writing Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame back
to back there were a billion cool things
that did not make it into the movie but
the visual effects artists are the ones
that they come to early on when they're
developing the movies with concepts
saying just go off on this idea make up
a scene based on these characters based
on
we're trying to do with the movie then
they'll come back later once the script
is finished or once they've actually
been shooting the movie to change things
as you can see during this scene it's a
very early version of what Hulk was
during Avengers endgame with them taking
him to full world break or Hulk freakout
mode during the movie there's a bunch of
Easter eggs in the background of the
scene that you probably spotted but you
also can probably tell when in the movie
this scene was originally supposed to
happen we never really got to see Iron
Man's new larger armory room in the New
Avengers base even though they developed
concept art for it before Avengers
infinity war picked up remember that
very first Avengers infinity war teaser
that I think dropped at the beginning of
2017 when they very first started
shooting the movie Avengers infinity war
is the culmination of the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe has started in May of
2008 with the release of Iron Man 1 Tony
senses his greater threat approaching
and so he is doing everything in his
power to keep the earth this was meant
to be what the armory was gonna look
like inside the New Avengers base we got
to see the outer wall of that room when
one of the Bay's open when Ironman
called the iron spider armor at the
beginning of Avengers infinity war to
save spider-man but we never actually
got to go inside the armory as cool as
that would have been even though Hulk is
talking to Iron Man during this scene
the reason why Robert Downey jr. is an
in it is because it's just part of the
scene that the visual effects people
working on while they were still
shooting with the actors so after this
moment here where the clip ends because
this isn't the entire scene this is just
part of it he goes completely world
break our old trashes everything in the
armory before they'll able to bring him
back down to regular Professor Hulk the
scene is basically meant to be an
alternate version of that longer
time-travel montage when they're first
testing out the quantum energy that
ant-man has given them in combination
with the Pym particles and because Iron
Man is supposed to be in this scene
obviously it's meant to happen after he
comes back to the team and they
quote-unquote get the whole band back
together you also probably noticed that
it's a really cool science bros scene
which we haven't really gotten since
Avengers age of Ultron the reason why
they didn't really do any science Bros
scenes during avengers endgame is also
the same reason why we never saw the
inside of Iron Man's Armory inside the
new avengers base and why most of the
other really cool deleted scenes did not
make it into the movie even with all
that stuff taken out it was still over
three hours long and adding all that
extra stuff in would have turned it into
a three and a half hour maybe four hour
movie even though I would love to see
the four hour cut of Avengers end game
with all the cool stuff added back in
but next talking about the Hulk versus
Thanos rematch fight so there's actually
concepts of the scene that they were
developing early on it was supposed to
be exactly what it sounds like
Hulk going up against Thanos to get him
back for beating his ass at the
beginning of Avengers infinity war the
Russo said the reason they didn't
include the big rematch during the movie
is because their big thing with Hulk
during Avengers endgame was that they
wanted him to be super Zen Hulk even
though we're all calling him professor
Hulk they didn't want him to be quick to
anger anymore he wasn't smashing
everything in sight impulsively at the
drop of a hat
so the Russos said that they felt like
he wasn't angry anymore at Thanos for
beating him up at the beginning of
Avengers infinity war in the version of
Thanos in the final battle wasn't even
the same vanos that he lost the fight to
the final battle was also another
30-minute sequence during the movie and
adding a big Hulk rematch fight would
have meant way more money in way more
time during that even though it would
have been super cool to see and I know
there's still a lot of questions about
why Hulk's arm still hasn't healed at
the end of Avengers endgame that will
heal eventually the Rousseff said the
reason why they wanted Hoke's arm to
still look like that at the end of the
film is because they wanted it to feel
like it actually cost him something he
had to sacrifice something in order to
snap the new Infinity Gauntlet
the damage isn't meant to be permanent
because hoax powers don't work that way
it's just gonna take a little bit longer
for him to heal that damage so by the
time they pick up with the events of the
she-hulk series during Marvel phase four
in a couple years he will have healed
most of that damage with his gamma
abilities I have some other theories
about why Marvel writes The Hulk
differently for the bigger Avengers
movies than they have for the Hulk solo
movies he's way less intense in the
bigger Avengers movies even though those
movies are meant to be bigger event
films I think that's mostly to make him
blend more with the quippy jokey Iron
Man tone that dominates most of their
group scenes when they're all together
if you want super dark intense Hulk be
sure to check out the immortal Hulk
comic book that's going on right now
it's written is a horror story a very
very hardcore version of the Hulk
written for adults instead of being
written for children like a lot of comic
books it's amazing it has also got a
thousand percent more Betty Ross than
the movies do right now but talking
about Marvel phase four now Mark Ruffalo
is supposed to come back before Avengers
5 for the Marvel phase 4 she-hulk series
he'll still be the professor Hulk
version of the character but obviously
they need him to explain how Jennifer
Walters gets her powers and he sort of
the mentor figure to help her through it
all really quick backstory explainer on
how she-hulk becomes she-hulk
in the comics Jennifer Walters is Bruce
banners cousin she receives a blood
transfusion with his gamma-irradiated
blood because of a mistake but that
blood then eye radiates the rest of her
body and that's where she gets her
powers so you kind of understand the arc
of what's going on during she-hulk she
can be the total destroyer version of
the Hulk when she first gets her powers
he doesn't understand them she
completely freaks out in her Hulk
persona in over the course of the six
episodes or so he helps her learn how to
balance both of her personas so by day
she can walk around as an 8 foot tall
giant green lawyer and by night she can
be a vigilante if you're a huge fan of
Red Hulk you also be happy to know that
because Marvel has the rights to do Hulk
on TV shows that's where they do all the
Red Hulk stuff for real because they're
also developing a Thunderbolts TV series
it's not going to happen for a long time
but there's gonna be three
new big Marvel series every single year
going forward after they start to get
them going
so of course eventually you would see a
thunderbolt series spin out of some of
the villains that are still around like
Baron Zemo during the Falcon Winter
Soldier series prime candidate to lead
that Thunderbolts series you could also
put general Ross Red Hulk in it because
they already considered putting Red Hulk
and Avengers endgame I've already got a
video about that deleted scene but that
was gonna be a slightly different
version of the character when people
heard about that they're like why don't
you do the real Red Hulk general Ross
from the comics well now because of all
these Marvel phase 4 Marvel phase 5 and
so on TV shows that's where you can do
that crazy Hulk stuff because normally
you would see that in a solo Hulk movie
because there wouldn't be time to do a
billion different versions of Hulk in
another Avengers movie and because all
the characters on the TV shows are going
to appear in the movies as well the
stories will crossover she-hulk will
also appear during Avengers 5 in some
capacity she probably won't be as big of
a character as the Hulk was during the
older Avengers movies but she'll still
be around for that Avenger stuff I'm
working on a new video about Quicksilver
coming back during Marvel phase 4 in a
new Mandalorian trailer video if you
want to request a special Marvel video
just let me know in the comments about
that - congratulations book buddy you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for my breakdown
of that leaked Avengers what if trailer
footage and click here for that brand
new secret birds-of-prey trailer video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]